So this is the rag stack we landed on
after 37 fails. Hi, I'm Jonathan
Fernandez and I've been working with
language models way before chat GBT
appeared on the scene. So I work as an
independent AI engineer and I help
companies build and ship production
ready generative AI solutions. Now if
you are new to rag I'll give you a bit
of an introduction but this is my
objective is for this to be the most ROI
rag guide per minute on the internet.
Now if you're pretty familiar with rag
uh then I want to give you the details
straight away right and this is these
are the headlines for the 37 fails and
the learnings from those 37 fails. So uh
I've broken them down into the
components that uh I would use in a rag
stack. So you've got the orchestration,
you've got the embedding models, the
vector database, the large language
model and so on. Now typically I'll
break them down into two components. Uh
a prototyping piece which I normally do
in Google Collab. Uh, one of the reasons
I use Google Collab is because I get
access to a free hardware accelerator.
So that just makes it very easy to
prototype. And then normally when I'm
working in production because I tend to
work with financial institutions,
there's a requirement often to have a
lot of my data and also all of the
processing taking place on premise and
so I'll often use Docker as my solution
because I can run it either on premise
or sometimes uh in the cloud if
required. So uh for the orchestration
layer there are couple of options right?
So prototyping I'd use llama index or
lang graph. Uh and then when using it in
production I'll use llama index. Uh with
the embedding models there are a couple
of options. So you can you go with
closed models and this is often helpful
especially when you can just use APIs
and it makes it pretty simple to use an
embedding model or you can use open
models uh such as the ones from Nvidia
or BAI. And again when I move over to
production then I'll use an open model
uh such as the one from BAI and Nvidia.
vector databases. Quadrant is an
excellent solution because it scales
really well. So I could be working with
just a couple of documents to hundreds
of thousands of documents and it just
works. And so quadrant is my choice for
a vector database. And then in terms of
language models, again I like to use uh
closed models here just because of the
simplicity of using APIs. If I want to
go ahead with an open model, I could use
the likes of uh any of the models from
uh Meta or I'll use a Quen uh 3 model.
uh and I'll do exactly the same thing uh
when working in production with a within
a docker environment. I normally use
Olama or hugging face uh text generation
in inference to allow me to um serve the
uh llama uh 3.2 models or the uh Quen
3.4 billion models from uh Alibaba
cloud. Now it's really important to be
able to monitor and trace your rag
solution. This just helps in terms of
troubleshooting. uh it helps you to know
uh you know where the majority of the
time is for example in terms of the uh
language model and other components and
so the two solutions here are
langu Phoenix uh for my prototype and in
production I'll often just use Arise
Phoenix uh because I can just very
easily use that in a docker container in
terms of re-ranking and improving the
accuracy of your rag solution uh again
my my go-to choice is a closed model
such as uh the one from cohhere or I
might use an open solution uh such as
the one from Nvidia and again in the
Docker solution I'd use the open
solution from Nvidia and then finally
it's really important to be able to
evaluate how good your rag solution is
doing uh and I'll use the raggas uh
framework there now in our time together
I'll be looking at just a single
knowledge base and if you want to get
the most of your time in terms of
understanding rag I suggest you just use
the next 3 to 5 minutes pause this video
and take a look at this knowledge base
uh because we'll be answering a very
simple question which is where can I get
help in London and so this knowledge
base is for a train or a railway company
operating in London and this is the
information in terms of HTML files where
you can go to each of the links and
you'll be able to get uh information for
that train operator. Now if you're new
to rag uh let me just provide a very
quick overview. So, rag is uh retrieval
augmented generation and so you might
have the initial user query which might
be something like where can I get help
in London and the first and most
important step is the retrieval step.
This is where you do a semantic search
where you look through a vector database
and you retrieve relevant uh documents
based on that query. The next piece is
the augmented piece of rag and this is
where the original query is combined
with the information that's been picked
up from the vector database and this is
provided as context to the language
model. This then allows the language
model to produce the generation piece
because it now has the required context
and the original query and so it can
provide a response to that original
question. Where can I get help in
London? So a naive rag solution looks
something like this. You have the query.
That query is then embedded and then you
want to then compare that to the
documents that are available in the
vector database. You then retrieve the
relevant documents from the vector
database. Uh and you pass that along
with the query to the language model.
The language model now has that as
context and is able to generate a
response to that original query. Now as
I said I like to prototype in Google
Collab. So, what we'll do over the next
few minutes is to take a look at each of
these different components in Google
Collab uh and see how they work. So, the
first thing you'll want to do is to get
and view the knowledge uh base. So, what
I'm going to do is I'm going to show you
the original knowledge base. And so,
let's look at the first two articles.
So, the first one is are there any
wheelchair friendly taxis in London? And
you've got the associated content over
here. So, most black uh cabs in London
are equipped with ramps and so on. And
let me take a look at the next one. So,
are there any wheelchair friendly taxis
in Paris? And then it gives you the
number for a taxi company and there's a
reliable taxi firm dedicated to
providing accessible taxi services and
so on. So, if you haven't had a chance
to look at this knowledge base, please
do take some time to look at it and uh
with that one question in mind, I'm now
in London. Where can I get help? So,
let's go ahead and grab all of the files
that we need and let's copy it over to
Google Collab. And so we have all of
this in our data folder. And these are
the relevant HTML files. Now I can look
at those HTML files either here or I can
view them in Google Collab like this.
And so these are the two files that we
looked at. Are there any wheelchair
friendly taxis in London? And are there
any wheelchair friendly taxis in Paris?
Now let's dig a little bit deeper and
look at what exactly are in the
documents. So with llama index, I can
use the simple directory reader and
that'll allow me to read through all of
the files in a directory which are my
HTML files, right? And you can see that
um I've been able to pull them through
over here. Now let's look at some of the
details of some of these documents. So
I've got uh 32 documents in total. If I
look at the first document, you can see
that I've got a document ID over here.
And then you can see I've got metadata
such as the file path and where the
information is taken from and so on. If
I wanted to see the actual text of the
document, I'm able to do that over here.
And you can see that this is the HTML
text for that first document. I can then
go ahead and move to the second
document. And in the same way, I've got
the document ID and metadata such as the
file path and the uh HTML file and so
on. If I want to take a look at the
contents of that second file, that's
available over here. And this is what
that HTML file looks like. Now, um, as
part of the metadata, I'm able to
determine the the actual location of
that file. So, this is taken from this
HTML file. And for that second document,
this is from the second HTML file over
here. Now, let's take a look at the
naive rag solution. Now, what's really
nice about llama index is that just in a
couple of lines of code, I have a basic
rag solution. So in that first line, I'm
going to be able to retrieve all of the
HTML files from from that directory and
store them in documents. I then take all
of those documents and store them in an
in-memory vector database. And I'm then
in a position to be able to query that
uh vector database with my question,
which is where can I get help in London?
I'm at the station. And you can see that
the first response using a naive
solution is not very satisfactory. You
can see that you can you can get help in
London at the station by approaching
London black cabs as most of them have
ramps and so on. Now if we want to get a
a more uh sophisticated uh rag solution
uh then there are a couple of components
we'll want to add. We'll want to add a
query processing step. And what happens
in the query processing is that we might
want to remove uh certain bits of
information. So for example, if there's
personal identific personally
identifiable information, then we'll
want to remove that before um passing
that to our rag system. And the second
thing we might want to do is we might
want to improve on the accuracy of some
of the documents that have been
retrieved from the vector database and
we can do that in the post retrieval uh
uh step after the information has been
retrieved from that vector database.
Let's look at some of the building
blocks of these systems. So what you
have is a cross- encoder. Now your
objective of having a cross- encoder is
to be able to semantically compare a
query with a document. Uh you want to
send both your query and your document
to a BERT model. Now a BERT model is the
encoder from the original transformer
model, right? You then pass that onto a
classifier and then you're going to get
a result between 0 and one and that will
indicate how semantically similar the
query is to the document. Now, as you
can imagine, uh the larger your document
gets, right, the less scalable the
solution gets because now you got a a a
rather short query and a large document,
right? So, this solution is excellent
for additional accuracy, but it's slow
and not scalable, right? So, let's think
about where we can put that as part of
our rag pipeline. The next solution is
where you can actually split things out,
right? So one of the challenges we had
in the original with the cross encoder
was the lack of scalability because we
had everything just running with one
model. Now what if we instead have two
models, two encoders. So we have a
separate uh encoder and a BERT model for
the query, right? Which then passes onto
a pooling and an embedding layer. And
then we have a another model right again
a BERT layer and a pooling model and an
embedding layer, right? And we have
those as two separate models. And then
we can compare how closely these uh the
query is related to the document by
using something like the cosign
similarity. Now what's great about this
is that by separating out these two
models right this is a fast and scalable
solution and this is excellent for
information retrieval. Now given that we
now have a better understanding of these
cross encoders and bioenccoders let's
try and figure out where we might want
to put this in our rag pipeline. Right?
So given that we have a fast and
scalable solution and we're having to
retrieve information and compare that
that query with multiple documents, it
would make sense for that by encoder
piece to be where our vector data is.
And similarly, because we're looking to
get additional accuracy, but we can't
scale and we are only able to work with
a few documents, then the cross encoder
would be a really good solution post the
vector database and so post retrieval.
And so this is where you normally have
your cross encoder uh which is al uh
also often known as a reranker. So let's
head back to our code and let's look at
swapping out some of the uh components
of our solution. Now previously we had
an in-memory uh vector database. Let's
go ahead and use a quadrant solution.
Now this quadrant solution also happens
to be an in-memory solution. Um, and so
as you can see, we've now got our simple
directory reader and we're using the
quadrant client. By default, uh, we'll
have a built-in embedding system, right?
And so you can see that by default, the,
uh, embedding solution that we have is
the text embedding ADA, uh, 002 from
OpenAI. Uh, if we want, we can swap that
out and use a text embedding three large
again from OpenAI. But what's what we
have as an option is to use an open
solution. So now we're not going to be
using a closed model with APIs, right?
We can use an open solution and actually
download the embedding model uh onto
Google Collab, right? And so what we're
going to do over here is we're going to
use the model from B AI uh which is the
BGE small model. Now if you want to take
a look at that, I've provided a link
where you can go to hugging face and get
a little bit more information about this
embedding model. And so we're using this
uh embedding model from hugging face and
we can go ahead and set that as our
default embedding model uh in llama
index. And you can see that uh over the
next few lines we've actually downloaded
that model onto Google Collab. And now
we have uh we've now set that up as our
embedding model. Let's go ahead and swap
out a couple of the other components um
in our rag pipeline. Right. So this is
our default settings. You can see that
by default we're using uh the GPT3.5
turbo model as our large language model.
It has a temperature of 0.1. And you can
see that we've got a couple of other
components. So let's go ahead and swap
out that large language model and let's
just use another model from OpenI which
is the GPT4 model. And this time let's
set the temperature to zero. Now let's
go ahead and make a couple of changes to
the benccoder. Right? So we know that
our vector database is going to be uh
the quadrant uh vector database right we
have our storage solution and now let's
go ahead and query using this new
language model that we have which is the
GPT4 model right and our new embeder
which is open um embedding solution
let's go ahead and query that and let's
see what sort of response we now get
from our rag solution right and you can
see that the response has changed and
you can get help so In response to the
question, where can I get help in
London? I'm at the station. The response
has now changed to, you can get help at
the station in London by arriving at
least 75 minutes before departure and
letting a member of the team know and so
on. Now, this again is not a
particularly helpful response,
especially if you've taken a good look
at the knowledge base. But let's try and
see how we can improve on that. Before
we do that, let's try and see where the
the rag solution was able to retrieve
this information from. Now in ll index
this is known as the source nodes and it
provides information about uh which uh
files were used to provide that response
and we wanted to take a a look at those
files we can do so by looking at these
source nodes right and so it's used
these two HTML files in order for it to
provide that response so can I get
assistance for a connecting UK train
journey and it's taking a look at uh
some of the information available here
and also uh information from this second
file over here now let's make our next
step which is to use our second
improvement which is where we're going
to use a cross encoder or our reranker
solution. So this time we're going to
use a closed model. So that's the one
from co here. And what we're going to do
is rerank the top two results. So again
back to the the five line lines of uh
llama index code, right? We want to go
ahead and pull all of the information
from the directory. We want to then go
ahead and use our vector database uh
which is quadrant. We then want to go
ahead and take those five results from
the vector database based on that query
and we want to then go ahead and use the
coher rank as our node postprocessor and
in response to that original query which
is where can I get help in London? I'm
at the station we get the best response
so far. So at London St. Pancreas
International. You can get help by going
to booth number five next to the Euro
Star ticket gates. Now, one thing that
we've not looked at uh but is an a very
important part of monitoring and tracing
a solution, especially when you deploy
it into production is uh something like
the Fenix Arise or the Langsmith
solution. Right now, what this allows
you to do is it allows you to determine
how long each of the different
components take. So another thing that's
really important is so far I've just
looked at this one question and I've
only asked this one question to the rack
solution which is where can I get help
in London. What you'll want to do when
uh when working with a rag solution is
to have a rag eval evaluation framework
that will allow you to test on a whole
load more documents. Now one really good
solution is the raggas solution in
production. I'm actually going to be
using open model uh the likes of BAI or
the ones from Nvidia. Vector database
quadrant scales incredibly well few
documents to hundreds of thousands of
documents. Monitoring and tracing um
again very important to be able to track
uh and troubleshoot your rag uh
pipeline. Um so Langmith or Arise
Phoenix uh in prototyping and then there
is a very good docker solution available
from Arise Phoenix that you can just
pull rerankers. um I'll use the closed
coher solution for prototyping but in
production I'll probably use the Nvidia
um solution that allows you to to do
re-ranking and finally rag evaluation.
Ragus is great and it allows you to to
check the quality of your rag solutions
across a couple of different ways of
looking at that and it works with the
large language model so it makes that
task pretty painless. Now just a quick
look at the production environ I have a
comp yaml file. This will work together
with Docker Compose. And then I'll have
a couple of the uh Docker images that
I'll use here. So for example, I'll have
an image for ingesting the data that'll
be connected to the knowledge base where
I'll pull in all of the HTML files. I'll
have an image for Quadrant. That's going
to be my vector database that I can just
pull from Docker Hub. I'll have a
front-end app for my solution. Uh often
I'll use Olama to uh serve my models,
but you can also use hugging face is
text generation inference engine here.
Phoenix for my tracing, right, and
Ragass uh to be able to evaluate my
models. Uh and then I can run each of
these images and have them as containers
uh within Docker Compose. And then I've
got and details about the different
models that I'd use for in the
embeddings and reranking and the large
language models over here. So these are
my results. These are my lessons from
the rag stack we landed on after 37
fails. I hope that this has been helpful
to you. I'm always happy to answer any
questions. So you're very welcome to
connect with me and uh chat with me on
LinkedIn.